greetings apiece welcome to the D show
Ramadan right around the corner I
thought it'd be a great opportunity to
go ahead and give you some advice with a
expert in the area of food and nutrition
we know that fasting is something that
has tremendous benefits in it we do it
for those spiritual benefits obviously
to gain God consciousness and it'd be
very unfair if I didn't just gloss over
really quickly the other four pillars
that we also live by in the essence of
education educating those that are new
to this way of life wanting to know more
about it and why Muslims are fasting and
this is the main reason is to develop
more God consciousness a direct
connection with the one who's given us
all of these blessings in life and the
first pillar of the five is that one
testifies believes in his heart and
testifies with his limbs and pronounces
that there's nothing worthy of worship
except the one who made me made you this
whole creation and everything in it that
there's no god but God there's no deity
with your worship except God except the
create tour and then Mohammed is the
last and final messenger and that would
automatically include Jesus Moses and
all the other messages that the crater
sent out of his love and mercy and then
establishing that direct connection no
middleman no confession box no weird
superstitions and incantations you dial
up direct you pray five times a day and
you give to the poor that's a right that
they have upon us and you make that
pilgrimage to Hajj first house of
worship built by Abraham to commemorate
the worship of the one creator the one
God and now fasting what Jesus did what
Moses did they all did Islam submission
to the creator of the creation we're
doing it today as we're living
continuing that legacy and now this
aspect of the show we're going to be
discussing the nutritional part we're
going to be discussing with an expert
who's conversant in this area how what
are the most nutritious foods we
and put in avoiding the fake foods
nourishing the body with real foods his
advice with an expert in this area you
can go ahead and make sure that you
benefit not only spiritually but
physically by not putting the wrong
foods in your body and then it just
makes the fast more difficult exciting
episode don't go anywhere we'll be right
back with nutritionist expert Jim Marlow
on the Dean show don't go anywhere
this is the
this is the thing you know this is the
danger this is the welcome to the Dean
show special guest Jim Marla no stranger
to the Dean show how have you been mr.
Jim I've been very good Eddie how have
you been good I've been trying to
develop the nutritional integrity my
councilman how did I go again for those
tuning in for the first time nutritional
integrity is all about setting standards
for what is acceptable food and drink
for your body and then being faithful to
those standards just like you'd want to
be faithful to anything else that was
important to I want to start off with a
story and then you're going to actually
give another real story when we were at
the farm okay I was on a plane and one
of my favorite topics nowadays is not
only talking about the heart soul but
also the body the mind I was taught my
food and we were I was talking to a
gentleman by the name of John and he had
talked about his grandmother she was
about 98 years she lived to a ripe age
about late 90s I mean 98 years old and I
was talking about how this generation
was the only Jenner one of the not
expected to outlive their parents his
great grandmother lived to that ripe old
age and then I asked what was she eating
and she had been raised on a farm she
was eating real food his mother had died
she had started to get exposed to the
fake food and she had only lived to I
believe around 57 late early late 50s
and then that was so I was so amazed on
you know the grandmother you know
there's a science behind that if you if
you study people who are eating real
food versus fake food and I want you to
get into the story I had done a video
not too long ago and I had mentioned you
and how we were at the farm and we met
that gentleman who was given two months
to two weeks to two months to live
yes can you should have story with us
and that goes also into the power of
food what we're going to be talking
about today yes well he had cancer and
the doctor had told him that he didn't
have long to live but he chose not to
believe the doctor
started doing everything he could do to
help himself nutrition wise and cut out
all the junk he had been consuming and
started nourishing himself with the best
quality food that was available to him
and at the time he we met him he was
going strong he was feeling so much
better he still had a lot of health
building work to do but he proved the
doctor to be wrong he proved that he
still had a lot of lifeforce energy in
his body and the body art the human body
is always striving toward healing and
health that's the direction of our life
force energy our body wants to be
healthy it knows how to be healthy it's
always trying to be healthy if you cut
yourself it heals there's there's an
innate intelligence and in and healing
capacity that that we all have we just
need to get our nutrition and the rest
of our self care white enough to support
the the healing potential that we have
inside of us why do you think before I
get into some of the questions and
advice you can give us for Ramadan sure
is that time of the year
fasting and why do you think many people
have become apathetic to this they when
you talk about food they don't many
people they just put anything in their
body and they don't take this serious
why do you why do you think that people
will have become apathetic to this
anybody who feels apathetic about the
quality of what they're putting into
their body is especially an urgent need
of improving their food quality and
improving their food nutrition so they
have more energy so they have more
mental energy to actually start caring
you know when someone when someone is
has relatively low energy low mental
energy their brain cells are not
producing anywhere near optimal amounts
of energy this will affect their mood
this will affect their attitude about
life what they see around them and
they'll tend to be more apathetic
because you know what it takes energy to
care about things and so when someone is
lacking energy they typically won't care
as much about about what's going on
around them or even care about
themselves so much so
when someone has when someone is lacking
nervous system energy when they're
lacking mental energy as well as
physical energy they're very prone to
being to be becoming apathetic about
about what's going on they're much more
likely to just kind of go along and
accept things as they are without trying
to to change things for the better for
themselves or for or for you know their
community because it takes energy to do
that you need vitality to affect change
do we see it now as a consequence of
this empathy towards this and we want to
motivate people to take this serious and
we're going to give the advice in a
moment but almost staggering numbers
close to 70% of people today are on the
verge of being obese overweight you turn
me out to a incredible documentary by Ty
Bollinger across the United States
interviewing doctors scientists
researchers and cancer patients so on
what they were doing to treat cancer I
recommend everybody to watch this the
truth about cancer at roof about cancer
global quest the statistic states that
50% of people living today will have
cancer one in four will die from it know
that almost 50% of the people alive
today will face cancer did you know that
one in four males alive today will die
from cancer and a driving force behind
all of these chronic diseases being food
oh sure the wrong food choices yeah well
we want to create some urgency to people
take this matter serious yeah well you
know food could be your best medicine
but food could also be you know your
worst poison because typically people
are eating at least three times a day
and you're you know when you're making
the wrong choices when you're eating
fake food instead of real food you're
insidiously poisoning yourself it's just
a matter of time before the consequences
begin to to manifest in regard to the ty
Bollinger series the truth about scan
sir my favorite episode was actually the
first episode which addresses something
fundamentally important and that is why
are things the way they are in the way
the conventional medical establishment
approaches
the treatment of cancer with just the
highly toxic treatments of the poisons
euphemistically known as chemotherapy
and radiation and surgery and and
conventional medicine
no attention is given to to nutrition
they gave us a whole hour on
Nutritionals a whole hour in whole hour
in four years medical school we got a
whole hour first of all how much
training did you receive on nutrition
when you were in medical school because
I know here in the states it's almost
none
yeah no much not much those two - yeah
yeah very close to none very little you
know medical school they don't teach you
they don't teach you anything about
nutrition which of course nutrition
always matters
in fact I've worked with many people
over the years going back to my days as
the chief nutritionist at dr. Mercola is
optimal wellness center worked with many
people with cancer over the years and
typically what they're told by their
conventional oncologists when they when
they're told they have cancer and they
instinctively they know that nutrition
always matters so they ask their their
oncologists the so called cancer
specialists you know well should I be
following any special diet now that I
have cancer and you know what they're
told that either told eat whatever you
want it doesn't matter hmm that is a
prime example of both ignorant and
arrogance ignorance and that they don't
know what they're talking about in
arrogance that they think they do know
what they're talking about eat whatever
you want it doesn't matter
that's ridiculous a four-year-old child
knows that what they put into their body
will affect the way they feel that will
affect their tummy you know it affect it
will affect them and so unfortunately
corruption and ignorance and the
arrogance is is something that is a big
part of the conventional medical
establishment as ty Bollinger's first
episode of the truth truth about cancer
really clearly makes Cleveland that
makes it explains why that is and it
makes clear you know why things are the
way they are and why nutrition gets very
little attention and the focus is on
these highly toxic treatments that I
mentioned
mónica we're going to take a break and
be right back with Jim Marlo and we want
to get some tips for Ramadan you know we
start fasting before the break of dawn
we get up with an early meal when I get
your advice so we can stay nourished we
can stay hydrated and we got just a man
to give us we got the shake of food you
know shake is right so we got our food
shake here shake nutritionism jim model
don't know anywhere I kept that is
another fasting makes you feel hunger
which every poor person suffers from in
the world this is how you would
sympathize with the poor and try to help
them war this is why every Muslim is
required to give food to the poor
immediately by the end of Ramadan the
basic rules of fasting are avoiding food
drink and sexual intercourse between
dawn and sunset in the month of Ramadan
other levels must be added to have real
impact on the fasting person the basic
level of fasting will not benefit one
spiritually except from the perspective
of submission to divine instructions
thus the ritual level alone will not
purify one of sin the deeper meaning of
fasting is training the spirit to
control desires restraining the spirit
from the lawful human desires for a
while during fasting makes the person
more capable of preventing himself from
committing anything unlawful at all
times not only fasting time it helps him
control the negative human emotions like
anger it also helps the person to
overcome greed stinginess and hatred
this is what the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him said Allah has no need for
the hunger and the thirst of the person
who does not restrain himself from
telling lies and acting on them even
while observing the fast back here on
the Deen show and we hopefully this
penetrated some of the things that we've
mentioned with the stories and you said
something very profound that even you
know the person instinctively knows that
this has an effect on their body right
and we want to put the right things in
our body but now specifically we talked
about in Ramadan you know we break we
start off in the early morning before
the break of dawn so what would you
advise us to put in our bodies to help
us because now these are long fasting
days we don't break fast till almost
8:00 in the evening for many people
especially here in America how would you
advise us to start in the morning what
would be the best most nourishing foods
and drink well I would strongly
recommend that everybody consider their
own life experience in regards to what I
call the real foods meats from healthy
animals and in fish and seafood ideally
wild ocean caught fish and seafood in
eggs and dairy products from healthy
animals ideally as we both appreciate
raw non heat damaged dairy products from
healthy animals rather than the
pasteurized to keep damaged dairy
products but then also you know
vegetables fruits nuts seeds grains and
legumes in regard to all of those real
food groups as I divide them think about
from your own life experience which of
those foods are most satisfying to your
appetite when you're hungry which of
those foods are best for your energy are
there any particular foods that when
you're feeling tired if you eat them
they help to boost your energy not in a
quick-fix way not just for a little
while but it has more staying power with
you the best that the foods that are
going to be most nourishing for us are
the foods that are really the ones that
are going to be most satisfying to our
appetite at the same time most
supportive of us having good energy and
as you know Eddy I teach
what I think is really an obvious truth
in that in our very diverse population
of people on this planet there is a
spectrum of possibilities for what type
of diet will be right for a given
individual there is no one diet that's
right for everybody in fact there is no
one food that's right for everybody this
was identified thousands of years ago
the the Roman philosopher Lucretia's is
attributed as the the person who said
one man's food is another man's poison
there's truth to that
what what works really well for one
person could actually be a problem for
somebody else but I teach that there is
no one diet that's right for everybody
there's no one food that is right for
everybody so it's important for us to
honor our own experience listen to your
own body and think of in regards to real
foods foods that that have real
nutritional value for the body again
meats from healthy animals and in fish
and seafood and eggs and dairy products
and vegetables and fruits and nuts and
seeds and grains and legumes of all of
those foods think about which of those
foods from your own experience you have
learned these foods are really the most
satisfying to my appetite and the best
for my energy and and then those are the
foods that I would focus on that you
start your day with and and also I think
it's especially important because you're
going to be going a long period of time
without eating and you don't want to you
don't want to do too much food
especially really early in the day when
your digestive system is just beginning
to wake up I think it's especially
important to eat very consciously pay
very careful attention to what you're
eating
certainly I'm all for seeing a personal
GRA saying a prayer before you eat that
has actually been shown to be good for
digestion
and so you want to whatever you are
consuming the real whatever the real
food you are consuming of course you
want to digest it as efficiently as
possible so you get the most nourishing
value the most energy supporting value
from it but in regard to meats we were
talking before the show we were talking
somewhat about meats and I was saying
that for someone who has who has learned
from their own experience that they need
to eat meat on a regular basis because
if they don't eat meat they're just they
don't feel completely satisfied and if
they don't eat meat it hurts their
energy I would say for for the the
Ramadan period where you're going to be
eating very early in the morning I would
recommend that you consider eating the
most nutrient-dense meats that the meats
that actually will have the most
nutritional value for your body and
that's not muscle meat which is most
commonly consumed but that's organ meats
like liver especially liver is the most
nutrient-dense meat there is there are
what I mean by nutrient-dense azar more
vitamins and minerals and liver than any
other animal food any other plant food
for that matter the liver is the richest
food source of vitamin A which is
absolutely essential for the health of
our immune system and through our eyes
and our skin and for heart health and
the B complex family of vitamins are our
in liver liver is a rich source of all
of your your B complex vitamins which
are your energy and anti stress vitamins
especially rich in vitamin b12 and
there's some vitamin C and liver which
of course vitamin C is important for
healing it's important for
cardiovascular and immune health and
every cell in the body needs vitamin C
and vitamin DS and the lever and vitamin
E and basically all of your essential
minerals are in liver livers of course a
specially rich source of iron but liver
is also uniquely rich in a mineral that
a lot of people don't know about called
phosphorus phosphorus is actually the
most important mineral for energy
production in the body
and so organ meats generally speaking
whether it's it's the liver or the heart
or the kidneys or the brains organ meats
are more nutrient dense than muscle meat
and so if you're only going to be eating
a small amount of food and then going a
long period of time about 16 hours this
time of the year before you're going to
be eating again consider consider organ
meats okay we're going to take a break
and we'll come back to talk about
breaking the FAFSA so to summarize
eating real foods seeing what your body
relates to best from from these real
foods that you mentioned go with that
hydration or how much real quickly water
is is there a specific amount some say
according to your weight half the size
of ounce ounces in that half of your
body weight in ounces of water is it as
a general guideline the quality of the
water is is very very important to tap
water no all right we'll get we'll get
we got to take a break we'll get into
that when we come back here to these
show don't go anywhere
the essence of the sciences of self
development and management of time and
resources in the world call for one
important principle control your desires
and do not let them control you in this
age of gratification many things are
used to fulfill human desires as soon as
they have them the ability to delay
gratification is an important skill and
fasting helps in developing such skill
fasting is primarily between the person
and Allah and because of this intimate
aspect of fasting Allah was quoted by
the Prophet as saying every act of
Adam's descendants is for themselves
except fasting it is meant for me alone
and I alone will give the reward for it
just wanna wanna
xena feel who Deline us you have a unity
meanin Buddha one football family demi
who shall waffle yeltsin
back here in the dean show preparing for
ramadan we want to eat the right foods
be nourished somebody's getting up and
may be eatin a snicker bar and some some
fake food you can give an example it's
going to affect you during your fast
isn't it and you're going to not be as
nourished as you would with real food to
get you through that day you know i
think it's you doesn't it make sense to
want to honor your body with the best
quality food that god nature have to
offer you and you know candy bars are
definitely not going to be on the list
of the best quality food that god nature
have to offer all of us you met you
mentioned now good quality water okay hi
this is very important some what what
about here's our Gatorade sport drinks
in the morning know what but
electrolytes no no no yeah it's also got
a lot of sugar and it's got brominated
vegetable oil which is really bad stuff
and you know Gatorade is not good not
good for rehydrating your body in fact
Gatorade typically makes people want
more Gatorade it actually makes them
thirsty for more Gatorade which if you
think about it from you know a from the
standpoint of of corporate mentality you
know they they want to produce products
that people will consume and want to
consume and keep consuming and over
consume and yeah it's that's best for
their profits yeah what were the things
that it has in there that aren't good
for you what was well there's there's
there certainly is their sweeteners in
there there's there's artificial food
dyes there's there's additives to excite
the tastebuds in there that have
addictive qualities to them there's what
something called brominated vegetable
oil bromine
are they can hurt the thyroid gland the
thyroid gland is the gland of the human
body that makes and secretes hormones
that regulate the rate of our metabolism
the rate of our metabolism has to do
with our energy and whether we're in
fat-burning mode or fat storing mode
there's other hormones that that affect
that as well but you certainly don't
want to do anything that makes life
harder for your your thyroid gland to
function well the so the best thing
would be to get these electrolytes in
your system and get you hydrated would
be what water well well
filtered tap water you would want to at
the very least get a get a if you're
drinking tap water get a filtration
system that removes the chlorine and at
least most of the fluoride if not all of
the fluoride but despite the propaganda
about fluoride fluoride is not a
nutrient for our health fluoride is a
toxin it's a toxic substance the fact
that fluoride can have a poisoning
effect on our body is is very evident on
every box and tube of fluoridated
toothpaste there is a warning it says if
more than more than used for brushing is
accidentally swallowed in the amount
they're talking about is not an ice
cream scoop amount of toothpaste but a
pea-sized amount of tooth basis the
amount they're referring to but it says
on every box and tube of fluoridated
toothpaste if more than used for
brushing is accidentally swallowed
contact a poison control center right
away so just using a little bit of
logical thinking
obviously if fluoride can have a
poisoning effect on our body
it affects much more than our teeth
because no one ever died from poison
teeth and so fluoride is a toxic
substance it's not a nutrient so it's a
good good good thing to do to get a
water filtration system that removes
fluoride you can buy water filtration
systems you can shop for water
filtration systems from friends of water
calm has fluoride removing water
filtration systems and also there's a
company called Cu Z
dot-com I went to that one you you see
and yeah you recommend you is the
chemical symbol for copper Xion is the
chemical symbol for zinc they use copper
and zinc materials and their filtration
to to make poor quality tap water much
more supportive of good I use also
berkeley water filter have you heard of
this one yes oh yes I'm familiar with
that one doubt that they have a fluoride
removing filtration okay so notice no to
tap water with the floor yeah well good
again unless you have a filter not non
filter tap water is not not supportive
okay good health all right let's get
down to now breaking the fast what are
you recommendations many people are they
fast and I've been guilty of this in the
past and then we in the feasting we
overload our system and we eat an
extraordinary amounts putting so much
overload on the system right after the
fast what do you think about yeah what's
a good way to how is is how bad is this
for your system and how what do you
recommend after you've been fasting all
day the first thing ii usually will do
some dates and and you know some to well
and then we'll go from there
mmm-hmm well I think dates would work
well for for some people but I think
getting back to what I was saying before
about how there is no one diet that is
right for everybody if you're if you're
a person who feels a need to eat
vegetable and fruit nutrition every day
and vegetable and fruit nutrition always
feels good to you and it's in if it and
it's largely satisfying to your appetite
if not completely satisfying to your
appetite and you do well with with
grains and nuts and seeds and legumes
that is you you thrive mostly on plant
foods then starting with some with some
dates could be good or I think even
better in the
in modern world where we have all kind
of insults that our body has to has to
deal with from from pollutant different
types of pollutants coming from a
variety of different industries you know
the more pollution were exposed to the
greater our body's need for nutrients to
counter the effects of them glutens and
so I was talking about organ meats being
the most nutrient-dense type of meat
well in regard to plant food nutrition
in this particular vegetable
I mean vegetables of all the plant food
groups vegetables really have the
greatest health supporting and health
building value for us and there's a way
of taking vegetable nutrition and
concentrating it and and and creating an
extract that requires very little
digestive effort on the part of your
body and that is to use a juice
extractor when you run vegetables
through a juice extractor what the juice
extractor is doing is it's breaking open
the cells that the vegetable is made up
of and it's releasing what those
vegetable cells mostly contain which is
water we call it juice but it's really
vegetable water and along with the
vegetable water come concentrated
amounts of vitamins minerals enzymes and
antioxidants but the vegetable the
vegetable juice as it's more commonly
called that is really the best quality
water you can put into your body so
you're not only you're not only
nourishing yourself with vitamins and
minerals and other nutrients with the
juice you're rehydrating yourself with
the best quality water that you can put
into your body is this is a good way
also to break the when you start sure
nourishing your body with juicing now
bad apples but yes you know you you run
you run some vegetables through a juicer
like some some celery some leafy greens
like lettuce or spinach or parsley you
put some some cucumber in there and
maybe a little bit of carrot or beet for
some people maybe a little bit of lemon
for other people who enjoy that but
there's a there's a lot of different
vegetables that that
that are good to juice but to to consume
that first that requires very little
digestive yeah give us something else so
someone doesn't have you know a
vegetable juice or something more
pragmatic you know that someone's on the
go what can you do well again it comes
down to what have you learned from your
own experience about which real foods
are most valuable for you real foods
real and in if in if and if and if you
do really well with vegetables you
naturally gravitate toward wanting to
eat some vegetables every day then you
know I would I would break your fast
with a salad with a with a very simple
salad dressing like some really good
quality organic olive oil and some
either some some lemon or some apple
cider vinegar just keep it very simple
something light easy to digest kind of
you know wake up your digestive system
we're almost out of time tell us how
could again someone distinguish between
when we say real food and a fake food
okay
well if you want to be real healthy then
eat real food in real food is simple
food that does not come with a label
with the list of ingredients real foods
are whole foods that you do whole fresh
natural foods that do not come with a
label with a list of ingredients nuts
and seeds grains and legumes grains and
legumes are always best when you buy
them you know dried and you you you you
cook them up from scratch ideally
soaking them overnight as a way of kind
of preparing them and whole fresh meats
and fish and seafood and eggs and the
best quality dairy products ideally as I
mentioned before raw from healthy
animals make a make a connection with a
farmer get by this this free organic
milk pasteurized no no well you know raw
dairy products is not is not readily
available to to everybody in America
there are ten states where people are
allowed to choose either raw dairy or
pasteurized dairy but in the other
dates you know people are basically
their choices limited they're basically
forced to buy pasteurized dairy in
stores but raw dairy products are and in
most states even though they're not
allowed to be sold at the retail level
they're not illegal there are no laws
against them it's just that you're
supposed to go directly to the farm to
get them you suppose they you know and
that's that's something I encourage
people do to do you know I think real
milk calm Rio melt calm is a great
website check out also there's a website
I want to recommend to people to go to
farm match.com farm match FA RM ma
tch so it's two M's in their farm
match.com is not a dating site for
farmers no it's a it's a website where
you can go to actually learn how you can
connect with farmers in your areas their
farm match.com thank you very much we're
out of time it's always great to be with
my good friend amiable friend Jim Marlow
and I like what you said you mentioned
and this is really what Ramadan revolves
around it's it's connecting the heart
you mentioned a prayer before you eat
and this is what we do you know it's
it's their prescribed to help us to
build more consciousness of our Creator
and this is the main focus of Ramadan
being thankful and grateful to that God
Almighty it's always good to eat
consciously and to practice if you don't
already do so practice eating slowly and
chewing your food thoroughly that's a
very simple thing to do that is very
conducive to better digestion some more
tips ok chewing all that just swallowing
in chunks yeah you use your teeth
they're there for a reason
thank you getting thank you for inviting
me back thank you it's a pleasure to be
here thank you for being with us and
there you have it some great advice with
chief nutritionist Jim Marlow some
pragmatic advice very simple concept
start off with real food and with real
food the staggering statistics that's
becoming an epic growing epidemic almost
70% of people living today are over B
weight and obese one in three people
expected to have diabetes heart disease
we're clogging up these pipes with junk
with fake food and no wonder our health
is deteriorating so it's a great there
are so many a we do this fast for the
spiritual benefits of strengthening our
connection creating more taqwa God
consciousness of our Creator and showing
that hey if we can restrain from lawful
things that are permissible during this
month food drink and other things
avoiding all of the things that we know
we shouldn't be doing backbiting
gossiping controlling the tongue the
eyes and we're straining from the good
things imagine now when we get enticed
after Ramadan if we were able to control
ourselves during the spiritual boot camp
how we go to another level when our iman
increases and we're able to go ahead and
shun off those temptations that might
come after Ramadan would and we were
able to control ourselves and stay away
from the lawful things now it's going to
be much eating easier so there's so many
tremendous benefits but now also there's
physical benefits a detoxification of
the body removing many of these toxins
that are acquired over the years and
science has backed us of so many
tremendous health benefits so we want to
make sure we also at this time we have a
complete balance we're also able to
nourish the body and give the body what
it needs and instead of feasting we're
fasting and wreaking both the spiritual
and the physical benefits and make sure
that we develop this nutritional
integrity we put real food in our body
avoid the fake food so we don't become a
part of this growing epidemic the
statistics of people who are having
chronic health issues that 95 percent of
those chronic diseases are food related
that's why this urgency should be
created to take this matter seriously
because 50% of people living today will
have cancer one in four will die from it
and a great amount has to do with the
food choices we are making
if you love your children you love
yourself Your Honor this gift that the
Creator has given you you're going to
take care of it it's a blessing and
those two things that we're told that
people take for granted is what our time
and our health
don't take your health for granted too
many people have and they're dead
they're in the ground it's too late
appreciate this blessing care for it
because it's an Amana it's a trust and a
great way you can start is by feeding
your body with the food that the Creator
has intended for you to eat real food
avoiding fake food and may you have a
blessed Ramadan we'll see you next time
until that peace be with you
Islamic take that simple step that you
asked your maker to guide you that he'll
guide you yes I advise this a lot for
people researching put your head on the
floor and in the in the state of
prostration like all the prophets did
and ask the creator of the universe to
show you the way to guide you to the
straight path and someone who sincerely
ask for guidance upon a little
foundation Islam that's it subscribe
right now